foreign
it was a highly anticipated visit and
Berlin pulled out all the stops
warmly welcoming arguably the world's
most in-demand president for the first
time since Russia invaded his country
no signs of the tension which have at
times fizzled between Germany and
Ukraine over the last year
a man on a mission to get more weapons
zelenski could hardly complain about
almost 3 billion euros of new military
aid and a promise of more to come
visit
we are also very clear on our message to
Ukraine but at least also to the Russian
aggressor we will support Ukraine as
long as it is necessary that is to say
we hope that the war will end quickly
also because military support support
with weapons will enable Ukraine to
defend its country
an ally which previously
and arms Germany is now one of Ukraine's
biggest donors but the generosity comes
with a caveat not to use Western weapons
on Targets in Russia something zielinski
denies he's been planning
regarding the Russian territory we do
not attack Russian territory we liberate
our lawful land we are not interested in
this we don't have time for this we
don't have the powers for this we don't
have Surplus weapons for this
it was part of a Whistle Stop tour
across Europe to drum up support
with a huge counter-offensive on the
cards Ukraine knows how important it is
to keep key allies close at times this
relationship has been strained but
president zielinski knows Germany is a
European Powerhouse and this trip is
important for ensuring the support of
not just politicians but also the public
and after Berlin to Paris to firm up
another friendship vital alliances if
Ukraine hopes to realize its goal of
defeating Russia by the end of the year
Sivan Robins Sky News Berlin